[Music]
in an interesting turn of events today
we saw the cover for Tony Stark Iron Man
number four and it's interesting because
the cover is of Tony Stark kissing the
wasp now for those of you who aren't too
familiar with the comics this is
actually Janet Van Dyne not hope Van
Dyne who will be playing the wasp in the
upcoming ant-man movie this is actually
a rekindling of the relationship between
Iron Man and the wasp as they've had a
relationship in the past their
relationship started in Avengers number
224 and it was kind of weird kind of
interesting because nobody knew who Iron
Man was it was not known that Tony Stark
was Iron Man and this was a secret from
the public and from his fellow Avengers
so the wasp and Iron Man were dating and
Janet Van Dyne had recently gotten a
divorce from Hank Pym who was the first
ant-man which is a pretty interesting
move for Tony scene as him and ant-man
were pretty close friends so eventually
Janet learns that hey Iron Man is
actually Tony Stark and then she ends
the relationship because Hank and Tony
are so close but it seems like they're
rekindling it now they're bringing it
back and as you can see both of their
helmets are off so they're saying that
this is not a relationship between the
wasp and Iron Man this is a relationship
between Janet Van Dyne and Tony Stark
so we'll see what really happens when
this issue comes out but I think the
real question is does this mean anything
for Avengers 4 or ant-man and the wasp 8
man and the wasp is only a few days away
and it seems like there are some
connections now that lead me to believe
that Iron Man might be making an
appearance in ant-man of the wasp so
there are two major signs that Tony
Stark may make an appearance in ant-man
of the wasp and the first is obviously
what we just talked about this new issue
that's coming out as I said Tony Stark
and Janet Van Dyne have had a
relationship in the past and we all know
that Janet Van Dyne is making an
appearance and is going to play a major
role
in ant-man and the wasp so Janet's going
to come out of the quantum realm and
maybe word gets out and Tony finds out
somehow and wants to pay a visit to an
old girlfriend granted if he comes in
for this specific reason it'll be a
small cameo but I think the fans would
like to see it second reason ghost is
actually an Iron Man villain not an
ant-man villain ghost terrorizes and
brings down huge corporations Stark
Industries being a main one in the
comics and if you've watched some of my
past videos on ant-man and the wasp
you'll know that I think that black life
is going to be the main villain and not
ghost
I actually think black Goliath hires
ghosts to steal Hank Pym technology and
to bring down Pym technologies so ghost
has terrorized Tony Stark in the past
and now ghost is gonna be terrorizing
Hank Pym and as I mentioned previously
Tony and Hank were pretty close so maybe
Hank gives a call to old buddy Tony to
talk about this new villain that has
appeared and taken his technology and if
this happens I think this will be brief
as well but again will be super cool to
see Tony Stark make a cameo in ant-man
on the wasp of course he may be too busy
fighting Thanos we're not actually quite
sure of the timeline yet for ant-man on
the wasp so what do you all think what
do you think of this new issue coming
out that is rekindling the relationship
between Janet Van Dyne and Tony Stark
and do you think Tony Stark will make an
appearance in ant-man and the wasp
that's coming out in just a few weeks as
always let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
hit me with some of your own theories
and be sure to hit that thumbs up button
if you enjoyed this video and of course
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on ant-man on the wasp Avengers 4
and all Marvel DC and superhero news
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]